most of us fly some of us a lot 300
million people flew in and out of the
top UK airports last year and these
passengers returning home to Bristol
were well aware of the impact they were
having on the climate I think we do need
to fly less I think it'd be a very hard
decision for people to me because we
just live with it it's a normal part of
life now isn't it I am thinking about
not taking so many flats I take a lot
actually we probably go stay next yes
stay in this country Sky News has seen
Airport master plans revealing that
they're hoping to grow passenger numbers
by 67 percent in the next decade or two
that's almost three times more than the
government's climate advisors say is
sustainable he throws controversial plan
to build a third runway we'll help it
add 50 million passengers to the 80
million that already fly in and out of
here and even if Boris Johnson does
block those plans our research shows
that three-quarters of all future
passenger growth actually comes from
other UK airports Southampton currently
flies two million passengers a year this
is going to saw to five million and
Doncaster Sheffield flies just over 1
million now but the airport is planning
for 7 million in less than 20 years the
second biggest Airport Gatwick wants to
boost passenger numbers from 46 million
now to a staggering 70 million in all
airports how to add another 192 million
passengers the rest of the economy is
having to cut carbon to almost zero the
airport's expansion plans horrified the
chief climate adviser
wellsure McChrystal liking to avoid it
it could not possibly happen it would be
impossible to meet our legal obligations
under the climate change at so there is
no doubt that you couldn't have that
expansion if it had that effect Belfast
City Airport hopes to almost double the
two and a half million passengers who
currently use it but it insists the
growth is good for the local economy
we're an island off an island so air
travel is essential
we're fortunate with airlines with young
fleets of aircraft so the newer
generation aircraft the more modern
aircraft of fuel emmissions so if we
grow with that type of product we can
actually grow and reduce our emissions
at the same time the Committee on
climate change warns greener aircraft
aren't enough and controls and frequent
fliers are inevitable later this week he
throws third runway returns to the
courts a huge test for the government's
commitment to cutting carbon Thomas More
Sky News